dire bonjour à ton
grand-père il y a cette opportunité
d'affa qu'on m'a proposé
elle peut pas rester rend-moi ce service
et ensuite je te jure que tu entendras
plus parler de nous t'inquiète pas de
retour tu auras pas le temps de
t'attacher
ça nous a affilé entre les doigts je
vais régler cette affaire comment tu vas
régler ça on fait tout pour protéger sa
famille tu veux revoir ta petite fille
tu
veux' qu'est-ce qu'il a fait ton
père dans le
camionord tu restes dans le camion quoi
qu'il
arrivees ches pour passer des ches que
tu dois pas
voir
tu vous
êtes je suis
boulanger est-ce que je peux vous la
confier est de votre
s 10000llar à celui qui trouvera ce
boulanger je cherche mon fils
[Musique]
le boucher est devenu
boulanger rentrons à la
maison